One of the hearings. I chaired, we had testimony from a guy, uh, named,
named Dr. Epstein. Oh yeah, I know about it. Um,
and he's a psychologist used to be the editor of psychology today.
He's an academic he's by the way, not a conservative,
he's a liberal Democrat who voted for Hillary Clinton and openly supported
Hillary Clinton. And,
and he did empirical research on Google's manipulative
search outcomes. So it's interesting psychology when you type in a search,
the auto-correct, the auto-fill in, not the auto-correct,
but what automatically populates makes a huge
difference. Um,
and the first few stories that come up make a huge difference.
And there was a dramatic differential between when you typed in Hillary
Clinton, it would, auto-populate good. All good things.
When you typed in Donald Trump, it would auto-populate bad things.
And the stories that would come up would be predominantly good stories for
Hillary predominantly bad stories, uh, for Trump. And what was interesting is,
is, is Dr. Epstein did the study and he concluded that in 2016,
Google's, uh,
deceptive search outcomes shifted
2.4 million votes to Hillary Clinton.
And he said this as a Hillary Clinton supporter, but he was, he was horrified,
but he also projected, he said in 2015, he said,
big tech is getting worse. It's getting more aggressive.
They could move as many as 15 million votes
to the Democrats in 2020. And so I think it's a huge threat.
We got the important stuff out of the way.
Let's talk about big tech because you've been right in the center of this thing.
As you know, I've been fighting it from my,
from my garage for the last five years. Uh, Trump did this executive action.
Uh, two 30 is the, is the, what do you call it? It's not, it's not a bill.
It's a.
So it's section, section 30 of a bill called the communications decency act,
right.
Basically what he did was stripped some protections from the big boys from
Twitter, YouTube, and Facebook. Now my personal preference.
And I think we're pretty close on this.
The libertarian side is you don't want the government running around sending
regulators to these companies cause that's not going to do good,
but stripping protection protections to me seemed like the
right idea. Do you agree with the right idea? Is it enough? Is it not enough,
et cetera?
I think it is the right idea. Um,
if it's something I'd been urging Trump to do for three years,
so I'm glad that that the administration did it. Um, listen,
I agree with your sensibility. Nobody wants government free speech police.
I mean that, that would be a terrible outcome. Some people do, but
nobody who's not insane. And that's a qualifier.
We can talk about some more because there are a lot of people that fall that
category, but government free speech police would be a terrible outcome.
But what big tech is doing,
it's deliberate. It's conscious, it's naked,
it's abusive and it's dangerous.
I think it's the single biggest threat to free speech and democracy
we have in this country, uh,
because big tech has become a monopoly,
controlling the instruments of communication. And you know,
I've chaired multiple hearings in the Senate on big tech censorship.
And one of the hearings,
we talked about a document that Google had prepared.
It's called the good sensor.
So they prepared it's PowerPoints about 50 page long.
And it talks about how the old vision of the internet was the
free speech, laissez Faire internet,
where people could speak and say what they wanted.
And then it talked about the new vision of the internet.
And this is Google's own words is the European style
censorship model. And by the way,
the four companies that Google identified as implementing it were Google,
YouTube, Facebook, and Twitter.
This is a conscious decision and the dangers are enormous. So the question is,
how do you fix it? If it is a problem,
we can have a long discussion about whether it's a problem, although
they're not hiding it anymore.
Yeah. I think most sane people at this point would agree that there even,
even people that disagree with us politically on this,
I think most people realize that the extraordinary amount of power is a problem
one way or no.
So I will. It's interesting. The political debate though,
one of the talking points at big tech in the left is they don't engage in
censorship. And the reason they say that is they say, well,
there are no objective data that prove we do. And it's,
you know,
there's the old aphorism of the PR of the guy who kills his parents and then
pleads mercy on the court because he's an orphan. It's true.
There are no objective data because Vic tech controls all the data and they,
they there's zero transparency, zero accountability.
So you can use anecdotes and I I've gone through lots and lots of specific
anecdotes, but every time you ask big tech and I've done it in writing,
I've done it in hearings, simple questions. Um, all right.
In the 2018 election cycle,
how many posts from Republican candidates for office?
Did you block or shadow ban?
How many posts from democratic candidates for office?
Did you block or shadow ban their objective answers to that? I mean,
there is a number and they know the number and they refuse to answer
it and then say, there are no data. And so how do you fix it?
I think one way to fix it is getting rid of the special immunity from liability
that big tech has that Congress gave them. So that's two 30, right?
That's two 30. And the reason two 30 was passed.
Congress believed big tech would be a neutral public forum.
In other words,
it wasn't fair to Sue Facebook for a
comment made by an individual comment or cause it wasn't,
they weren't the speaker, it was someone else. And so that was,
that was Congress's reasoning.
So we're going to give big Texas immunity from liability because it's third
party speakers and we want to see the internet grow well.
What's happened is big tech changed their mind. And they said,
we're not going to be, to use the language of the Google document,
the laissez Faire free speech place anymore. We're going to sensor well,
you know what, if they're going to silence views,
they disagree and promote views. They agree with they don't deserve.
I don't believe as a public policy matter,
a special protection vote for liability. There's also the antitrust laws.
Google is a monopoly by any measure,
big tech is richer, stronger,
more powerful than at and T was when it was broken up under the antitrust laws.
They're bigger than, than us steel was, uh, a line from the godfather.
We're bigger than USDA where they're bigger than USD, um,
and that abuse of power. So I've also,
you want to talk about the real,
what the Trump administration did on section two 30 will be challenged.
It's at the FCC. There'll be litigation.
The real bite here is federal antitrust
litigation, which, which I have urged the president to pursue diverged.
The vice-president pursue have urged the attorney general to pursue I've urged
the chairman of the federal trade commission to pursue urge the white house
chief of staff to pursue I've urged the white house counsel to pursue, to,
to force the transparency,
to get the answers and to stop their, their, their naked bias.
Are you worried though,
that as we sit here right now in the middle of July only, you know, three,
four months before an election that insert in a certain way that the ship has
already sailed the damage that they've done.
And even if you could get everything you wanted tomorrow pass tomorrow,
by the time the processes and the systems are are implemented.
Congratulations.
I am deeply worried about it. One,
one of the hearings I chaired, we had testimony from a guy, uh, named,
named Dr. Epstein. Oh yeah, I know about it. Um,
and he's a psychologist used to be the editor of psychology today.
He's an academic he's by the way, not a conservative,
he's a liberal Democrat who voted for Hillary Clinton and openly supported
Hillary Clinton. And,
and he did empirical research on Google's manipulative
search outcomes. So it's interesting psychology when you type in a search,
the autocorrect, the auto-fill in, not the auto-correct,
but what automatically populates makes a huge
difference. Um,
and the first few stories that come up make a huge difference.
There was a dramatic differential between when you typed in Hillary
Clinton, it would, auto-populate good. All good things.
When you typed in Donald Trump, it would auto-populate bad things.
And the stories that would come up would be predominantly good stories for
Hillary predominantly bad stories, uh, for Trump.
And what was interesting is, is,
is Dr. Epstein did the study and he concluded that in 2016, Google's,
uh, deceptive search outcomes shifted
2.4 million votes to Hillary Clinton.
And he said this as a Hillary Clinton supporter, but he was, he was horrified,
but he also projected, he said in 2015, he said,
big tech is getting worse. It's getting more aggressive.
They could move as many as 15 million votes
to the Democrats in 2020. And so I think it's a huge threat.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.